youtube is my tv ads like you know
tv-theek over radionl youtubers taking
over tv
the channel met everybody watchers met de
hoop family watches and i in sixty
seven percent and fiftysix in older
decision makers people at many people
gathered in tanks people that one alarm
tanks
i decision makers and companies i tell
you tips youtube is my charming and
nephews opportunity for you and
family this is your late to get started on youtube
ar youtube and this thing is so three
platform family to start dessing my
time my energy and probably sam  dollar
bills
youtube this platform yes and cds episode
all those things media podcast
who live in the pinch uw ten steps de
unit nl
you will make great decision on of
youtube is right for you
my name is had returns and you're
listening to the pink  media podcast the
number one podcast de help you grow your
implants on youtube and antique dutch
english and gray
high impact and a high-profile online
business and two hours of doing so  mething
other before you die charlie my love
you our story i love to including a
case studies with idea who all
the fack studay is already dead the numbers
week house
oh my beauty make and educate the
decision when chance you investing
your time now a cane  my cd you can
replace your money but you can replace
your eyes of you can be in west in your
time
into a platform for nature the new
reggiano de youtube is de re platform
for you and this person is brought to
you by art link
masterclass al  talimoda a view to the
speech er content zo let's jump into
[Music]
what's the state on youtube intro not
online
wide web statistics you didn't quickly and
took it is you know star youtube there is
so opportunity in youtube live i know i
think  media podcast that yes it is of
course the star youtube and latex look
it's a number sangat and the van state
pray for you and others of what that means for
as to be made better videos and more
money and grow a glance busine  ss is and
in faster
celebstyle a new song line solid
youtube youtube get more than 2 trillion
montly logged in users fast so that
hasn't been updated in a while but i'm
feeling that soon we're going so an
update u the city  this is not quite large
and the audience on facebook
which is to point seven for trillion mp
active users at keep in mind that has
porn watch youtube with oud evergreen en
en capt
re zo de two trillion of blood and users
min 2 heaven and hell
they  have gmail account check if your man
hey youtube account manager man have you
become police so what youtube at an
action login and comb and a also click
like and videos enzo
login mowgli users like glue and reports
bisexual number of people watching
youtube opportunity  and there is someone present at the
chair chair games after winters scarlet fever
argue that you can get a life impact of
this people but unlike super youtube
users with an icon
leaving comments and dropping like an
applied for number two three fo  ur
percent of the village and the usa youtube
that is killer facebook giveaway for your little
bit 16th percent american adult
and it weiss is margin as the neck
sweater on instagram
watches for the process so short in the
pew research youtubers the most popular
online platform in america
and wi-fi building the village this makes me
think about perfect
youtube is not just for young people ark
bij de two all people ar that moment
when ambition marilyn your goal is
a youtube i u ground to the building
your empire week it is not necessarily
just for one generation r younger
generation number 3 and the us alone
youtube om make up 5-point five six
trillion dollars and advertising revenue
intro not from someone with the trillions
have more than ever imagined money money
and more people buy more and more for
maps
where is that minus 4 you admin's lab lessons
dollars of flying in second platform
zoom in the cable tanks number why and
advertisers youtube italy ball number 2
julia gift at re  venue wesley van you
give my eyes really the monetization on
youtube
is a fifty five oli white river splash
heavy essential niëns to over to play
5 trillion dollars is can i go into
creators pockets in the form of earth
save your power for ibeacons basically
level by  chose two creators and box
numbers of grooming
growing up gimmicky bienes mental
delicate competition is so high with it and
he started two of youtube mel
de platform is the lot more dollars of
floating in and took in sofie van moll
microlife it is a blue moon' gdb  youtube
millionaire well it is more practical than
ever before
for people de there 5 10 15 20 515 times
here on youtube of course be
discontinued de flora in terms and
advertising revenue number for him love
7%
and 15 de door die 5 euros de us use
youtube zo youtube's most popular with
users 351 underbelly slightly 17 percent
americans first by that sex the foil
[ __ ] you you belong with 7 not percent
on those days for the sixty 1565 7% en
fiftysix an old one
so no longer youtube something for the
client in the detectives after all also
a tree but youtube is for everybody
this is a far idea from the
mother's platform social medi platforms for
usually
stairs for older age groups and of
course tik tak tik  tak
jesse raging on youtube is white tv ads
like you know tv-theek over radionl
youtubers sign under tv
the channel with everybody watchers met de
hof family watches and i in sixty seven
percent and fiftysix en onder de social
meters
people at many people gathered in  tanks
people that one alarm tanks op decision
makers and companies i bag of chips
youtube is my charming and nephews
opportunity for you informal number 5
point for percent on youtube site
traffic comes from the
us once experts and is from outside of us
which is crazy  pea cafe is the vld
youtube is people in the us by youtube is
absolutely nothing found
the world that barbies half an hour ways
you too busy to keep at it  keep in
mind on a fraction of youtube graphics
nikon sony es according to relax ss tee
mens
wat de us is the single largest source
advisors for youtube it still only
peppers and 16 point for percent an
expert at night politicians and on
youtube you were sorry in  india and for
pre-press and erin chip and zo youtubers
international
youtube and google youtube is a chance
to give your message mission
though the world and impact people around
the world and box number sars zo massa
for talking about two billion blood
money and logged in  users and bigger
numbers are not logged in
i am in a micro netsh view all in
one of its people in china of india of
young man there is something people know us there
is plenty of you try their audience
you to the customer your taille Personen
impact en  help him there sex
youtube is the world cao smith in it
website night repair and company google
a little further test that youtube is
massively popular and is not gonna be
the way
de by any  other video platform number 7
just like the world
sec post use social platform in this
case it comes from behind
facebook en zo in light of all these
other platform switch iphone scratches
i know and live news and cyclos and
leader experimenting in building in
films on instagram of  driving in de
tiktak
if you are professional when something
professionals linkedin youtube sambeek
this is why we continue general lee
focus on youtube and think media help je
booty tube
week is youtube is the second moshi
social platform en en arabia patch en
die energy that fly  boys survey
brilliant'
we for you make a decision to really
double down and build your empire
qua youtube hint of butter empire
right number usa team and over spam foil
my boy my minutes on youtube
deliana bridge this includes across
devices mobile death star or laptop  and
connected to be bought an average
and 5 hours a week and early to higher
than fifty five hours muscle
wish she even less will so  neat
line up and and mercury for other viral
video learning moment
importance rowing of time consuming content
on youtube
girly and hours a day in east c&a never
a union like a city sorbet
here in america people edgemont 2 hours
pvda edit and shifting to youtube
there is  de mee and sell content and
specifically neat in some specific
questions and and this is number
streetwise about this here and seliga more
videos posted on line for the pipers and
on youtube watch time happens on mobile
huizes ensysteem hey is a drill de
[ __ ]
yes mobile content  rotterdam in smeking
share your words on screen avenio large
an atari and mobile you then with it as
nature crowd it begins keeper other
mobile devices as mobile devices or
smaller mobile devices and notifications
print those other distractions as a
game
oil eyelashes and on youtube watch time  my
t-mobile
hello ever ben numbers ben drinking and
people spend more time watching tv other
the idea its a silent significant
press  on view in time
nos is a man called jean of us back
and ever i opened up youtube almighty
closer is the first place aiko mit
want sony and ilife and iwork thermal
down over tarzan
edgar mitchell with masai medici's
cooking dinner and rewatch the news and
was phil defranco wie so they be watched
this scorel
fine obstacle course and how is your iphone
5 minutes of i school i already had
gore's video
live love it i enjoyed a dream in
another scrub like youtube begins to
watch your viewing behavior
he was  so in the animals that would
recommend it all the time of videos
uruguayaan is a omaha beach trails
amal analog real estate and the city
marks are really huge
you guys work with the box thai videos
or ketchup anne news and watch a
noise neck freestyle lite
diy were  watching live could be om or
smart tv wedges
broken and that's why should i take away
is metal noise here strategy and the
cities on youtube
be thinking mobile offers thinking smarty
be be  thinking people sitting back on a
couch
of sitting down and talking to their
exact me apple remote and a like
hey siri notk htc arnhem etica the school
the microphone down and i just say he'
rimec on youtube red series thaksin the
background headers without in  the podcast
my fall apologize
olivier and thither effort and the
average citizen for youtube
check out day source nine pages idea who
name him in cd cases heroine video
those gays nine jeffrey pages
that that's a good video like how
love that prestage like  a de of
sea jazz videos on a page
showing them your face and the tan nelson
demille content
that's called an impression ai-managers
i s'pose an efficient click to your
video i will here is people and archer
swinging youtube jack online video in
that channel euro
check out nearly nine pages including
both their true view in time
increasing poster for viewing time and the
number of constant
source is content source sdk samsung
gear ze bottom line
youtube a growing youtube is alfie and the
youtube economy is for template urge
you to teach people were watching and
listening to the think media podcast and
why you why i stepped up on
youtube start posting on youtube oh man
to reinforce
it  anyway already and that you have to be with
the ai even morso
the next decade of growth die youtubers
can experience in all these numbers
backup my name and i already do and elkana
for a more videos better quality videos
and a stable smile for the climb  my
digital real estate
clare knifelike in my niche on youtube
take my skis of de paille de viewer
shipping growing viewer chips and it
just my strategy according to some of
the day the point which another they
had ddns episode i wanna lose you
advice to catch  me kill nuances in the
fingerboards my strategy' with the
sucking group sub group
sieben i am anne vet in the watching
tank media lessons in the [ __ ] media
podcast and i am like nl posts de
video from libosan few weeks ago novella
have a posting my first videos to do
reconnaissance am still do and research
from the goddess step van ring and start
hosting
carpaccio van de face punch
perfectionism in the face and press
record ten years ago i never believe there
is  a small tai chi chu things major him
you my version video granny webcam
inside innergetic er entertaining at the
return in tiel and empire by just started
and he start it messi he started
before i was ready ready is a live
show started
and he the script  learning and i want
your over here controlled cooling tank is
not always obvious and yours is to
league a continue to grow about the next
and
and when you smell those cities week
ssd the box the something like airtime
single only on youtube with built a
preview
and nothing for it  check-up recipes are
that I will be this one youtube is already live
and hopi and well and en viewer ready to
double down on youtube red eagle already in
and neat creed youtube chan  nel
mowgli create sustainable online
business and business where you can work
from anywhere and business where you can
find your freedom and time freedom to
spend with the people that matter
motion you doing things you love you more
than eyeliner recommend your next up is
you go to  war for youtube glass this is
a youtube glass it is not on
youtube mini your edge line the
sign up for this class should i got you
think masterclass that can
you'll be there for in one hour glass
vase art work  share video
die drie secrets to success on youtube
and what i wish i were then the everly
if you were the beast earning in youtube
channel today with class is al die
details release of the parties ik a
one from as a highly recommend you go to
this  new class over red pink masterclas
john and if you had a ja let t corbulo
a youtube video or 3d de en reviews the
podcast about on itunes
die hoop de double be something they
used to do a loving you wi  ll surely the
super reviews and for this now in the
comment section and today serbio chance to
josh josh and inside a big fan of sean
and header van der donk media youtube
channel and now something like this alibi neger
de had podcast in high be
disappointed by feel like  some many
times die ever podcast en jazz bass
and motivational audioclips widget gray
banana or something looking for use with
information this is me who is what
podcast is ivy league etc
deep dive into en for marketing and
grading skills for youtubers we t
double box of  inspiration and
motivation drone and say you actually a
pie de skills california die episodes
every single i just wanna thank you so
much for de valued and music by
insided is podcast you guys de site so
tardis
uncas wat things sharona at was dat we
won make sure  you were not bring in
the
motivation confused you the fax where are you the
city and we bring you the experts you
the hp group hi there is any time on this
issue o  f podcasting is a could you bring
you potassium and anyway much as this
podcast every single day they shall i
know you and giving you the value
de juni to help jona donnie gill je
youtube channel but also your business
number the goal of vision on a
businessman  on a businessman and a means
you're youtube channel
is your business all the do you think burkina
faso family for commenting on youtube
videos for like i was on social media
and for sharing this with friends arno
de you know someone in your life rina op
u  his entrepreneur who should be doing
youtube is a content greater
or someone you know this creates and
should be
running  this
episode and will catch a
in the neck signed by
[Music]